we're learning more and more about the
absolute fury that overtook donald trump
after seeing
one of his two impeachment attorneys
yesterday bruce castor
aimlessly uh uh wander
through his personal background the
political preferences of his parents
praise of senators a discussion of
pre-revolutionary war british law really
everything but the subject matter of the
impeachment during his opening
statements yesterday which lasted about
50 minutes or rather not opening
statements the opening to
the day one proceedings to determine
whether the senate has the jurisdiction
to try a president that is no longer
in office as we talked about yesterday
the senate voted 56 to 44 that yes
they can have the impeachment trial
there's a report from
cnn that donald trump was quote deeply
unhappy with the performance of bruce
castor
multiple sources familiar with trump's
reaction said to cnn that trump was
borderline screaming
as uh bruce castor uh was failing
uh humiliatingly embarrassingly on uh
global television yesterday and uh
particularly was upset that those
opening remarks from bruce castor
were rambling trump's team also
was reportedly confused uh about the
last minute decision to swap the order
of his defense
caster who did the 50 minutes of
rambling first
was actually scheduled to speak after
david shone
and people around trump thought that
this new idea of having bruce castor go
first wasn't a particularly strong idea
now of course they were right how much
of it is hindsight bias i don't know
uh but they say that donald trump was
particularly upset
when the first thing bruce castor said
when he got up there was
the house managers the prosecution did a
really great job
and of course it was true uh it was true
that they did a good job but it's not
typically what you want your defense
counsel to be
uh admitting the new york times also had
a report in which they said that caster
getting up there and praising the
impeachment managers was not
well received by donald trump and they
reported that
uh some of trump's uh legal team were
actually surprised that there would be
raw video shown from the january 6th
riots
this to me you know we said when your
own legal team
misspells united states as united
states that should be a signal
that maybe they're not playing with a
full deck when it comes to
preparation and democrats had been
saying for days
we are going to show video of the riots
uh trump's defenders were saying well
trump's lawyers are going to show videos
at some point of democrats calling for
violence
okay well so everybody knows what to
expect
but reportedly trump's legal team was
surprised that there was video of the
riots
shown oh i sort of half jokingly five
percent jokingly said
during the uh proceedings yesterday does
bruce castor get fired today by donald
trump apparently it's actually something
trump is considering
the daily beast was told by a source
familiar with what was going on
that donald trump is considering pulling
bruce castor from the legal team
altogether which would put everything on
in particular on david shone which would
be a
uh a lot of work to say the least as far
as the schedule goes the impeachment
trial is expected
to go uh through the week and into next
week there are going to be
um eight hours of presentations from the
house managers eight hours of
presentations from trump's defense
council
there will then be it's either four
hours total or four
hours per party of questions
for the uh impeachment managers and
defense counsel
and then there will also be closing
statements so i'm expecting at least
into monday or tuesday although these
things change so quickly that
that the plan the plan may change
relatively soon trump
furious with bruce castor understandable
why
why can't trump just get people who are
adequately prepared to represent him in
a way that's not embarrassing maybe it's
because a lot of lawyers know
they're probably not going to get paid
by trump since he stiffs people on legal
bills
i don't really know the answer but it
just will not stop
one of our sponsors is privacy a free
service that protects your credit
and debit card i use privacy every time
i buy something online i installed the
app on my phone and the privacy desktop
browser extension
now when i pay for anything privacy
autofills a virtual
credit card number the money's taken out
of my bank account i don't have to give
out my real card number or banking info
to anyone
you can create and delete the virtual
cards anytime
i especially love it for free trials
because i can destroy the virtual card
number
as soon as i give it to the company and
i know i won't be charged in the future
privacy also has a feature called shared
cards
which makes it easy to split payments
with friends parents can manage a
virtual card for their kid
with spending limits businesses can
manage virtual cards
for employees to use for company
expenses there are premium
plans available but privacy's regular
service is totally free to use
and right now they'll give you five
dollars just for signing up when you go
to privacy.com
pacman the link is underneath this video